[Music]
from the pagodas of myanmar to the high
rises of singapore
from what were the killing fields of
cambodia to the pulsating heart of
jakarta
640 million people you have 300 million
muslims
120 million christians 150 million
buddhists
tawis confucianists thailand malaysia
the philippines and vietnam
asean is one of the world's most complex
regions
we have such huge diversity and such
ability now to create business
asean has a combined economy the size of
indians
the opportunities are massive but so are
the challenges the importance of
borders particularly in our regions is
fading away
southeast asia is a region at the
crossroads an emerging economic
powerhouse
whose future depends on how it moves
forward
key decisions made now will affect asean
the next generation
[Applause]
hello i'm hazlinda ahman we begin here
in thailand where a little over 50 years
ago
asean was born five countries that came
together
fearful of the advance of communist
china a lot
has changed since then
vietnam myanmar and cambodia have joined
from
difficult times and the region's
economies have been growing on average
more than five percent a year every year
for the past 10 years its biggest
achievement
is to take the most diverse corner of
planet earth
where of 640 million people you have 300
million muslims uh
120 million christians 150 million
buddhists
taoist confucianists and in the most
improbable region of planet earth
you produce peace and prosperity
[Music]
we have moved a long long way and i
continue to be very optimistic of course
there's always the doom say that asean
hasn't moved i think it hasn't gone
further enough
but look at airasia look at the
inter asean travel the inter asean
commerce that goes in our cargo shows
that
we have moved a long way and i remain
very very optimistic about lcm
different countries have different stage
of financial sector development so it is
up to the context of each country
but standardization might be needed
to promote cross-border financial
integration within us
and it's not so much of standardization
having one using standards but i think
making sure that domestic standard of
each country
is in interoperable particularly when we
talk about cross-border
payment activities this
is the golden triangle i'm in thailand
that's myanmar and that's laos the river
the mighty nikon which flows all the way
to vietnam
this area infamous for its opium trade
is just one small piece
of the jigsaw that is asean the
10-member block is made up of vastly
different nations from indonesia with
the world's biggest muslim population
to tiny brunei each with diverse
politics
rules and religion asean's 640 million
people account for around 9
of the world's population and its
combined gdp
of around 2.8 trillion dollars puts
asean on the same level as the uk
france and india we have countries that
are exceptionally rich
like singapore and brunei and you have
countries
that are quite poor like laos and
cambodia
they belong to the same organization you
have countries that are
incredibly big like indonesia with 270
million people
in singapore with 5 million people but
that's
that creates a certain degree of
complementarity
among the asean countries
the cost of moving goods via customs to
speed
the single window hasn't come to
complete fruition yet
and asean has to sort itself out there
quickly
otherwise the likes of china and india
will dominate e-commerce will dominate
trade flows is there a sense that asean
nations are competing
against each other more than they're
cooperating i i think there's a that's a
that's a real question and that's that's
a real
the real answer is yes um
and but you see it in china a little bit
as well you you get one
province trying to compete with another
right that rivalry exists
obviously in asean it's national so it's
a little bit more
one of the key milestones of the group
has been the creation of the asean
economic community
set up in 2015 the aec's end goal is to
create
a single market which is fully
integrated into the global economy
for trading goods it is effectively a
single market
and what we need to work on further is
that there are still some areas of
non-tariff barriers which need to be
managed
but i've been working on the aec for
many many years
for at least 20 years when we were
negotiating the details of this
agreement
and when i look back over this 20 years
i must say that
i'm quite pleased with what it has
achieved it's a it's always a question
of whether you regard it as a
cup half full cup half empty and i would
say that it's more than half full
from where we started i'd like to see a
common market
i would love to see freedom of movement
of labor that might be a step too far in
10 years
but if i can get a common market if i
need common ownership
you know why can't airasia own 100 of
all our airlines in asia
rcn should benefit the citizens of
aseans
in in various dimensions um you know
financial integration
economic integration trade integration
even
to have a common uh policies towards
economic sustainability
um you know the the importance of
borders particularly in our regions is
fading away
[Music]
at this time of year a huge haze
blankets
large parts of northern thailand myanmar
and lars farmers are burning off their
fuels
clearing land after the harvest their
produce packed away
in small rice meals like these
connecting smes to the fourth industrial
revolution
is one of asean's greatest challenges
the cost
of financial
services is coming down dramatically
with fintech
with the digital technology we are not
only able to provide those
banking services insurance services to
many more people
but also to people in remote areas
because what what is important now is to
have a mobile a smart mobile phone
and that is changing the shape of
financial services
this is the secret genius of us young
asean is the most imperfect organization
in the world in fact when you watch
asean in slow motion
it takes two steps forward one step
backwards one step
size it's like a crab going around in
circles right
but you slice asean decade by decade it
keeps growing stronger and stronger
and one of the reasons is that asean is
very flexible
so the consensus principle is a very
good
principle to have because it's very
flexible
it's hard to believe that 440 million
people
in asean do not have bank accounts
that's next as we continue to explore
asean
the next generation welcome back much of
southeast asia has been built
on small businesses like these in some
economies
smes account for as much as 90 of the
jobs
but despite that the number of unbanked
remains huge 440
million people that's the combined
population of the us
and germany put together
people often talk about tapping the
unbanked but so far that's been quite
difficult in fact they've been targeting
mainly the underbanked
what are the challenges that the
different
um dimensions when you talk about
tapping the unbanked or people who are
underserved we have to have a clear
policy with respect to
the types of products and the types of
segments that we want to promote
for instance in in thailand we have had
very high household debt and it could be
certain segments of
the population that are overly indebted
so we we need to promote fintech
together with responsible lending
policies to make sure that
they you know get better service at a
more reasonable cost
using new technology and not
contributing to
to to a more problems that would lead to
you know financial fragilities for them
i think the rating agency type
uh credit bureau the credit guarantee
program
as a resolution could also be ways how
to help support
uh access financial access uh to the sme
at the same time i think the digital uh
financial solutions could also be a way
for sme
to have greater access to the financial
pool because the better
information accuracy so that risks could
be accessed
different countries have different
stages of financial inclusion
for thailand the access to bank deposit
account is not low by by emerging market
standards
but with more concerns about you know
cross-border payment transaction i mean
the cost for
cross-border payment transactions in
and out of thailand is among the highest
in the world so we want to address that
and fintech can come in and and you know
providing
new types of technology cut out the
middlemen and
allowing new players to come into this
market
for the traders of myanmar to the rice
farmers of cambodia
for businesses in hanoi manila jakarta
bangkok fintech is forging a whole new
future
but the key words keep coming back
sustainability
connectivity and inclusion how do you
ensure that countries like cambodia like
vietnam are not left behind
well first i'll say that vietnam has
made tremendous progress
so we we we have this
when we launched the inclusive growth
program the there was special
consideration
for cambodia laos and myanmar
to access infrastructure funding for
instance at the battle rate
so those are practical initiatives we
need to do
there are also special considerations in
for
training and retraining of workers of
providing technical and vocational
training so
those are important practical measures
and because the
cost structure of these economies are
still
lower than the other asean members some
investors do find
them attractive as a company airasia has
embraced digital
with the onslaught of fourth industrial
revolution how prepared
is the region for what's to come
well i think we're a bit behind but boy
we're catching up
i mean if you look at the fact that the
tech unicorns in indonesia or
usage or viber in philippines or
line in thailand and their growing
amount of e-commerce
and the growing amount of connectivity
through mobile phones and applications
is not far behind
the thing that i keep telling people is
you need scale
right you need scale and so asean in the
tech world
needs to have scale i don't think we're
far behind
i think education needs to catch up a
bit i think we need to re-skill people
in that human capital but i've always
been
one that asean adapts very quickly as
soon as they see the opportunity
we will adapt but i think
we have an opportunity to leapfrog if we
can
adapt a few things i think the
integration among
the neighboring among the asean members
have been very significant and that has
been possible
with the aec 2015 and that has led to a
significant
change in the gdp growth from say
about 1200 u.s dollar per capita income
two decades ago now to about 4
300 us dollar per capita income which is
quite significant
in terms of financial integration how
difficult is that given that the 10
member nations
are all at different stages of
development
actually because of different stage of
development they are complementary to
each other
in certain countries like singapore
malaysia thailand for example
we are in access and other countries are
also in the
need of money so i think we can support
and
each other in that way complementary to
each other definitely
fintech can improve productivity um
in you know the asean countries um you
know financial systems in aseans are
a big room for for improvement and
technology can play a big role
fintech can also help enhance financial
inclusion within the region
because you know the cost of servicing
different segments of the people will be
coming down substantially using fintech
so 10 nations different cultures
languages and religions all at different
stages of development but
is there an asean identity we'll explore
that next
in asean the next generation
asean in its first 50 years has been a
government government-to-government
project it's governments to government
cooperation
now we're going to create a greater
sense of ownership
of asean among the people of asia
and here i'm glad that the asean
countries have copied the european union
practice
so when you go to london and you go to
any asean mission they have the national
flag
and the asean flag is there an
asean identity and a lot of people have
interviewed have been pretty divided and
whether there is one
no i don't think there is and i'm i'm an
aseanist
i've been promoting this word why not
for a long time
well i think uh what does asean mean
to the common man and that asean needs
to work harder at the brand and identity
does asean affect the common man
probably the common man of street sees
asean more as a threat than an
opportunity
in terms of asean identity there's a lot
of work that is going on as well
on the social and cultural aspects that
runs in parallel with our effort and
financial integration
economy integration but as
trade and investments increase as
tourism increase
i think we will see a far better
understanding
and appreciation of each other in asean
kun chatsuri
is there an asean identity
in many sense yes we are 600 million
people
with a diverse language culture and
identities but on the other hand in
general we are
relatively easygoing people
uh and i think that is an advantage of
how we could work well together it's not
just
identity mobility across borders
is one of asean's biggest challenges
labor
goods and the flow of money here people
come across the border from myanmar
every day to work and trade in thailand
but often in asean borders represent
barriers
to business
we have for instance you know a more
than three million my workers in
thailand but it's very costly for them
to transfer money back
to myanmar we have a lot of a lot of
traders that do
you know body trades very expensive for
them to
receive money and also to pay money to
countries in in in along the border
so you know fintech can help and come in
and improve financial inclusion
in this aspect in in a big way one of
the issues is
labor crossing borders how do we resolve
that issue
how can we have standardization that is
a sensitive issue because
the free flow of a labor it is not on
the cards because
you would you have different levels
of readiness for that a greater exchange
of people at certain levels you know say
a certain professional for instance
now that is being pursued the labour
markets are
at different stages of development
across asean
and what is important is for us to focus
on how we can integrate the economy
through trading goods through services
through investments and
if we are able to generate good growth
across different parts of asean the
people in each country will have
suitable jobs we have good jobs the
other thing that we
we have um we we work with central banks
in the regions and have seen
very good progress is on promotion of
usage of local currencies
for trade and investment two years ago
we started between bank of thailand and
banknotes around malaysia to promote the
use of thai baht and malaysian ringgit
for trade and investment activities last
year
bank indonesia joined in so we had a
thrive party arrangement and this will
help you know
narrow down the the the foreign exchange
spread between the local currencies
and also provide choices for for
for business people in the region to
minimize their foreign exchange rate
depending on where you live in asean the
block's future looks
very different for the big companies and
the big cities
is not only access across asean borders
but also to the global market
for the tens of millions of small to
medium enterprises
it's access to any markets workers want
to get work where they can
and parents want to educate their
children that's the reason
asean is known as one of the most
diverse and complex regions
in the world minnesota your vision of
asean for the future
well i think we hope that asean remains
you know a safe
prosperous and place and for which
we we can each improve the you know
well-being of people living in asean
all this work that we are doing on
economy integration financial
integration
on promoting fintech and so on
ultimately has one simple aim which is
to improve the well-being of our people
in asean
and with that i think we can maintain
peace and prosper peace and stability in
asean
we contribute to the global peace and
prosperity
i think many respect that we are seeing
in the western countries we see more
in us in with greater
wealth generated so there will be more
demand and diversity greater
segmentation
and certain areas like the wealth
management
probably will increasingly be
significant and important
i think asean should realize within
itself
what are the strengths and what are the
weaknesses some countries obviously have
very strong ability to do certain things
and other countries have a different
singapore is never going to be an
agricultural giant um
it's never going to do but it's it has
very strong
financial infrastructure so i think
each country should not try and
replicate everything
but see where they have the niche we
have a lot more economic activities
we have a lot more common problems
that we have to deal with and and
technology will basically blur the
the boundaries across across countries
so we have to think more in terms of
creating
win-win opportunities in in our asean
integration
framework to promote growth and to
promote sustainable prosperity
for us in citizens i think asean will be
much more careful
and pragmatic so there'll be controlled
flows
of labor and already if i'm not mistaken
millions of indonesians
work in malaysia singapore has got 1.7
million foreigners working in the small
island city state
uh of singapore thailand gets a lot of
workers
from myanmar coming in so there is this
movement of labor but there will never
be a kind of the kind of
freedom of movement that you have for
example with the european union
my dream for us young is that it will
continue to stay together and not break
apart
as a result of u.s china rivalry because
it's one thing that keeps me awake at
night
it's worrying about how asean will
survive
this incredibly intense u.s china
rivalry
that is coming in the next 10 to 20
years
from source to ocean the mekong river
flows for more than 4 000 kilometers
the main artery that for centuries
connected
this part of the world but times are
changing fast
massive infrastructure projects and the
digital revolution
are creating a whole new future thanks
for watching
asean the next generation